is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story live from the headquarters of
ramsey solutions broadcasting from the
dollar car rental studios it's
the ramsey show where debt is dumb cash
is king and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host christy wright ramsey
personality number one
best-selling author of the book business
boutique is my
co-host today as we take your questions
at triple eight
eight two 825-5225 the call is free
and some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
christy is also in olympia washington
and is our first caller of the hour hi
christy how are you
i'm good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
okay um i'm a little nervous um so bear
with me
um i've been dying i've been i've been
dying to
have a reason to call you and i finally
do um
we have a house in california that we're
currently
renting out my husband's in the military
we bought the house before he joined
um so we are renting it
out currently we're not making any money
on it
um we consider just raising the rent
just to make ends meet
but my question is um we're due to we're
on track to move again
in six months to new mexico
ultimately we would love to be back in
california back into our hometown
should we sell it yes
i know
and i knew that was going to be your
answer but i didn't know what you
thought with the current market
what you thought it would be and um
let's try reverse engineering it okay
you're in the military
and you're moving from city to city and
you're not going to be in california for
at least five more years
correct and you don't own a house there
let's pretend you don't own a house
there and you woke up one more and
thought
you know what i'm going to go over in
this little town in california and buy a
rental house
that i don't make any money on
you would never do that right
and yet you have yeah sure so let's undo
it sell it
and and okay so now we currently
might be um profiting like a hundred
thousand
would we should we just put that into
something and let it sit there so when
we do
come back to california we got a a big
chunk of change to put down on a house
or should we
buy something in new mexico that makes a
great house fund do you have him diving
debt though
no no debt we have 30 000 in the savings
wonderful
okay yeah i would just take whatever
profits you have of course pay your
taxes on it
and set it aside in a um future real
estate
mutual fund put in a mutual fund and
just in your in your mind you could kind
of mark that file
that's my house fund for the future and
you can keep adding to it by the way if
you want to that wouldn't hurt anything
and uh by the way there's not a law that
says that you're necessarily going to
end up back in california when you're
done
five years ago you never dreamed you'd
be where you are right now
that's true we do want to be back in our
hometown with family that would
be our goal and that's and that's why we
have a smaller mortgage right now with
that house
i would just be afraid of coming back to
california and
and then getting into a bigger mortgage
than before just because of the prices
well the problem is you're going to lose
money between now and then and you're
going to wish you had
just not had to fool with this whole
thing you're better off not
long-distance landlording you're better
off not fooling with this it doesn't
make sense
and so um and we're not i mean i know
it's your goal to be back there but no
one knows i mean five years is a
long time a lot of stuff happens in five
years yeah things may change
dave you use this example a lot so speak
to the principle
at play there because regardless of the
circumstances christie's question was
about the house but
i hear you say that a lot okay let's
reverse engineer it if this was not true
whatever the circumstances are
would you go do it would you go buy it
would you create it the answer is always
no
right that the question answers no not
necessarily i mean you know uh
if i didn't own a ski boat
i'd be buying one this week because i'm
going to the lake
this weekend right but i'm saying
something that someone's trying to get
out of i guess
i mean the point is she do i keep it or
do i sell it yes
and you can ask that about anything an
investment you can ask it about
a ski boat you can ask it about um
whatever
but if you look at something and you say
if i didn't already own that i wouldn't
go buy it
for the very reasons that you wouldn't
go buy it you're not using it you don't
like it it's about investment
it's whatever it's the same reasons you
wouldn't keep it
that was what i was going to ask so
whenever you ask the question if this
weren't true would you go do it are
there ever circumstances where
that doesn't apply so you're saying it's
like if the answer is yes i would go do
this today anyway
then then you'd keep then you know okay
okay so for instance let's say um
the the first place this always comes up
is within a pure investment like let's
say
let's say you um bought stock
in i'll just make up a company home
depot
okay about stock at home depot and let's
say you bought it at 75
a share and it went down to 50
this year and you said gosh i'm gonna
wait on it to come back up
i go well would you buy stock at 50
a share yeah because i've got real
reason to think it's going to come up
right then you would sit and wait to
come up and you say
oh no i wouldn't buy the 50 a share i
wish i hadn't bought it at 75
a share because i think it's going to go
down then why then why are you falsely
waiting on it to come back up to be your
measure of when you sell
it you need to say you don't analyze it
based on the past you analyze it based
on the future
yep okay you're forward looking with
your decisions and going
okay if i wouldn't do that again now
then i don't keep doing it just because
of the past yeah
and that's an investment is called a
sunk cost analysis
what you've put into it your cost is
irrelevant as to whether you keep it
virtually irrelevant i mean you may have
some tax implications but it's virtually
irrelevant the
the investment analysis should be and
for that matter the possession of a boat
should be
the future of that not my family's
always had a boat i've always had a boat
this boat's not been in the water for 10
years it sits in my garage collecting
dust
but but because of the past i'm going to
continue to keep this thing in the
garage
yeah okay well that's dumb yeah but if
you're going to use it this weekend and
you've always used it in the summer
then you would go get a boat or you
would keep your boat in that case
so you're looking forward with all of
your decision-making analysis
uh not the past the weight of the
emotions the
weight of the cost of the item not that
and so you know if you would go and buy
a small house in a small town in
california because you're afraid real
estate prices are going to go up
and if you didn't own it now and you
would go do that now i wouldn't suggest
that but
if you would do it then maybe you would
keep it different and that's where we
see it the most
every time i host with you it's always
around real estate i had a house
i'm holding the house now i'm renting
out the house and it's another
state and the house is almost always
inherited into that situation meaning
no one's set out in those situations to
be a landlord right
right it's a landlord by default is
where most of those questions
come from yes i became a landlord by
default i got married
we moved into her house but we kept mile
house as a rental that's landlord by
default
we're in the military we moved we bought
a house everywhere we've been and every
time we move off we turn it into a
rental property that's not i decided
that's going to be my rental
investment strategy it's landlord by
default yeah
and it's not wise it almost never leads
you
to a good real estate purchase yeah or
are keeping the right piece of real
estate
as an investment uh i i own
one piece of property that i formerly
lived in
right now and it's a great rental and i
would buy it again as a rental so i
i passed the acid yeah but but you know
there but but the house i currently live
in would not be a great rental yeah
it's too stinking ridiculous you know so
not a good idea so it's
gonna be sold yeah no that's the deal
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they
offer benefits like tuition assistance
career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is the
co-host
of the ramsey show today the christie
wright show
is where you can hear her on her podcast
it's where faith meets personal
development
so you can have a bigger faith and a
better life get the encouragement that
you want and the tough
love truth you need to connect with god
take control
and enjoy your life new episodes every
tuesday on youtube
and anywhere you listen to podcasts
the christy wright show be sure and
check it out phone number here is triple
eight eight two five
five two two five our question of the
day comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake
your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more
use the promo code ramsay to get the
best possible
deal today's question comes from nema in
maryland
my husband and i have no debt we have a
significant savings account considering
our income and my husband is super
responsible with the budget
the problem is that i can't stand to
budget i hate the accountability
the time it takes and how confusing it
is
besides for just sucking it up and
telling myself to be a big girl
what can i do to shift my mindset
and my actions this is interesting to me
because i'm curious
i feel like there's more there of why
don't you like it because it really
shouldn't be that confusing especially
if you have no debt and you are
using something simple like every dollar
where it's actually fun to drag and drop
your expenses and their categories and
um
you know i don't know i don't know if
you don't if you don't know why
something matters you don't want to do
it but if you could see the payoff of
how you actually
control your money versus it controlling
you then the means to the end becomes
worth it i don't know what do you think
dave what
what else is she saying in that question
um
but i'm not sure there's obviously a lot
of possibilities
number one um yeah you need to know why
you're doing it
uh because otherwise just it's not
confusing it's really not that hard and
it doesn't take that much time
once you start doing it so it really
does come down to
the accountability and uh
you know so if you're self-admitting i'm
a princess and i don't want to be told
no
even by my own self for my own good
then you might as well eat a box of
donuts at every meal
and be 800 pounds i mean if you have no
self-control whatsoever
yeah and no accountability to for your
own benefit
yeah i mean you know it's just it's just
misbehavior
it's just immaturity at that point but i
don't think that's really what it is
here
um i'm kind of thinking
that that you know i'm a spender and i
learned
to love the budget because it gives me
permission
to spend that's what i'm saying i wonder
if what she's saying without saying it
is her and her husband
don't see the budget the same so like
for her she doesn't feel the freedom to
put in the budget what she wants to
spend money and feels that we have money
to spend on i don't think she's got a
voice in this yeah but she hasn't
bothered to take it either
she's copping out yeah yeah you know i
just need to be a big girl there's a
little whining going on
yeah so uh you know yeah you do need to
be a big girl and you need to speak up
and say
okay we've got plenty of room in this
budget we make plenty of money we don't
have any debt
and we're going to put some joy in the
paper here
you set the budget you can make it look
like whatever you want it to your money
yeah it's your money but you're not in
congress you can't just spend
not infinite you just can't keep going
and going and going and going going that
doesn't work so
yeah you do have to have some boundaries
but they that but they're your
boundaries you get to set them
so a i think she's probably not speaking
into it doesn't feel like she's got
control
b probably nerd husband's got the budget
too tight yes
to where there's no joy in this thing um
and then see yeah you do have to be a
big girl and suck it up
yeah uh there's part of that in there
too no whining allowed but it might be
that you just need to
take control of this it is a spending
plan
yeah it's how you're going to spend your
money yeah so it's not saying
you know dave ramsey doesn't want me to
ever have fun again oh shut up
the whole point of living like no one
else is later you can live and give like
no one else the whole point of
paying a price to win is and oh by the
way it's your choice dave ramsey's not
coming to your house
right and straighten you out right every
night when you misbehave
i mean this is a matter of are you going
to be a grown up and are you going to
control your destiny
that's all it is it's not me telling you
and and i don't think that
you need to live on beans and rice the
rest of your life and i don't hate poor
people
i have been both um and it's easier when
you have a little money so i'm trying to
teach you how to have a little money
it's that simple
uh so you know the whining
lefties are just beyond belief but
they're there and so
she's not that her thing is she just
isn't speaking into this and she doesn't
feel power
yeah and i feel like she's gaining power
over her life and this thing
is being used by her husband to control
her yeah yeah and she points out we have
no debt we have significant savings
considering our income
and my husband is super responsible for
the budget there's all the backstory
why can't you i can't stand to budget
you need to answer the question why
can't
you stand a budget and she says i don't
like it's confusing it takes time that's
bull
it's absolutely bull yeah she's not
represented in the budget you're not
represented you don't have
any say you don't feel like you have any
say maybe he's not
being hardcore but you're just
anticipating that he is right
maybe that's the way you were raised i
don't know what's going on here but
but there's there's something about you
need a voice in this you need to set it
you've got some room you need to put
some fun
some joy on the paper enjoy
your money some of it but then yes you
need to have
guard rails we all you never make enough
money to not have guardrails yeah
i mean i make a lot of money and i have
guardrails yeah you know i have
boundaries you have a plan
there are different boundaries than when
i was broke yeah but there's still
boundaries there's still guard rails you
know you got different different
situations
so all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five thank you for joining
us america
we're glad you're here christy wright is
our co-host
if you've been paying attention the real
estate market this year you've noticed
that competition out there is
really high it's a cray-cray real estate
market in part because
inventory has been hitting all-time lows
it is truly a seller's world
now when inventory is low it simply
means there's more buyers buying than
sellers selling which turns the pressure
up the price is up the bidding wars
start
this is not amateur hour you don't want
to be playing out there without a pro in
your corner
you're going to get hammered to win in
this market you need a pro
by your side if you're buying or selling
a monkey can sell a house but not
necessarily for the right price
and lots of monkeys wouldn't got their
real estate licenses this year
a bunch of them they've sold two houses
in their entire life and you're going to
put your largest asset up for sale with
them
dumb idea now you need a pro in your
corner and you can instantly connect
with one of our
endorsed local providers high octane
high protein real estate agents
dot com slash agent find a ramsey
trusted
agent near you ramsey solutions dot com
slash
agent open phones triple eight eight two
five
five two two five you jump in and we
will
talk linda is here in boise idaho hi
linda how are you
hi dave and christy thank you for taking
my call
sure um this call is probably more for
christy
my son uh played in the minor leagues
for the cubs
and he's also been a high school
and a college pitching coach
but that that's in the past and he would
like to
start his own pitching
consultant business um
he works full-time this would be on the
side
and i would be the manager
so what do you do to get started
i have i have so many follow-up
questions linda is this something you
want to do
i know it's his idea i know he's good at
it i know all that but let's talk about
you for a second is this something you
want to do
yes i'm retired it'll give me
something to focus on i i'm all in
okay what does he uh what's his vision
for this business he works full-time
this is a side gig is it just for fun
is it to make some extra cash does he
want to grow it to be the full-time
thing
uh probably just for fun when he goes on
the baseball field
he sees young children you know third
fourth
fifth grade uh having poor fishing
mechanics
which could affect their future one
linda hang on hang on through the break
we're gonna answer your question when
you get back so we can dig into this
yeah we want to dig into a little bit
more and give you a good solid answer
we'll be right back with you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to ramsey show kristy wright
ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phone's a triple h
five five two two five we're talking
with linda
in boise idaho her son is wanting to
start a side gig
doing pitching coaching he has been a
professional ball player
and he's asking his mom linda to run the
coaching business i guess while he does
the coaching and christy was in the
process of
helping her with that yeah so linda
let's do a quick recap
when we left and went to break i was
asking you what's the vision for this
business so
is this going to stay aside business
does you want to grow it to full time
let's kind of pick up there
i think probably for now it would be a
side business
um he just got his master's in social
work so he'll be
working professionally with children
on that side so this i would just be
keeping into the baseball okay well
i'll tell you what jumps out to me first
there's there's a lot you want to
plan for especially because you would be
running something that is
your son is actually fulfilling the uh
the business side of it of the coaching
consulting pitching you know that type
of thing
here's what i would get really clear on
linda really clear
what is he doing and what are you doing
let's get real clear on that
what does he want you to do for the
business is it the books is it the
marketing is it the day-to-day
admin work um who's wearing which
hats so who's wearing the marketing hat
who's wearing the accounting hat that
type of thing obviously he would be
doing the
uh actual coaching but when you say
running the business that includes a lot
of things and i'm curious if there's
aspects of that he wants to do or
expects to do
and then what he wants and expects you
to do just just get on the same page i
would actually write it out i would sit
down and get really clear you know what
does this look like to you let's define
it let's let's write it out
and then also what are um goals
vision expectations you know how many
hours does he want to dedicate to this
um how much money does he want to make
through this do those correlate
um you know what what market does he
want to serve and is that market there
in your in your town and your city that
type of thing so i would just get
really really clear on what he's doing
what you're doing and then i would baby
step into it
he sounds like he's got a full plate
already of things and this may seem like
a great idea that when he gets into it
he's overwhelmed so let's just take it
uh one step at a time one
client at a time one you know and you'll
you'll learn a lot when you get into it
about what he wants to do more or less
of what you want to do more or less of
but i would take it slow start small
grow slow
and then you can you can build on it
more once you learn a little bit
i'll definitely um what do you do for a
living
she's retired you're retired how old are
you retired nurse
you're [ __ ] nurse how old are you
70. okay all right and um
is he wanting to do this for you
no okay he loves baseball
i know that but i mean is he wanting you
to start is he wanting you in this
business to help you are you struggling
with money
no okay no we're he's
independent we are independent
we've followed your all of your things
for years okay all right cool i just was
making sure that
what the motivations were behind all of
this and what's going on so this is just
simply him wanting to help some kids
learn to pitch
properly and um he doesn't want to deal
with the administrative and
business side of it he just wants to do
the pitching part and you pick up the
rest that makes sense
okay cool well i hope it works out i'm
with christy let's baby step into it
move slow into it incrementally
so that you guys can learn as you go and
figure out what's your next step
let's her a copy of business boutique
that'd be great reading for her anyway
as she's kind of having these
conversations with him
absolutely that's perfect so kelly i'll
pick up linda and send you a copy of
business boutique
elizabeth is with us in canada hi
elizabeth how are you
hi i am thankful to god for his
blessings
amen me too
um so my husband's 29 i'm 34 we're
expecting our first baby in july
we don't have any debt except for our
30-year mortgage
we have about 280 000 left on that
and we've only owned it for a little
over a year we have
thirty thousand dollars in our emergency
fund and
we have about forty three thousand
dollars just
sitting in our savings that we've saved
up and kept there
and we're kind of a little bit divided
on what to do with
that so my husband looks at the numbers
and he
wants to put it in investments for
retirement
and i hate having the house debt and i
know that it's
not a huge chunk in relation to what we
owe on the house
but i know that it would help pay down
the principal and i just i hate
owing on the house i don't like the debt
and we don't have any other debt so it's
like that's the one thing
um so but numbers why is he thinking it
won't get us ahead
as fast as investing will when you're
looking 30 years down the road
so i guess with the question is with
that 43 000
chunk should we pay down the principal
on her mortgage or invest
now or split it somehow or just i could
just say screw it and get
a brand new toyota tacoma that would be
like
well that's possibility okay
i mean if you're on board there you go
the uh uh
i mean if you have a purchase that you
need to make other than a screw it
purchase but i mean a legitimate project
that you want to make then that might be
a play but basically what we teach is
what we call the baby steps and it
sounds like you're aware of them baby
step one is
and two is to be debt-free everything
but the house three is an emergency fund
you've done that beyond that you have
this forty three thousand
which we would apply to uh beginning
your baby steps four
five and six simultaneously four is
putting 15 percent
of your household income into retirement
are you doing that
um well okay so yes and no so not 15
but so the coolest thing is actually at
my husband's job
he makes about 90 000 a year and i'm
going to be a stay-at-home mom so i was
working but i'm not so our
let's just say we make about households
90 000. so
at the end of each year his um company
gives him 12 of his annual income above
what he made
and we use that solely for investing so
it's not
we haven't he just started there he's
only been there for a little over a year
so
we've only received one and that's just
a that's a lump sum bonus
yeah exactly and so i think it's
intended for investing and that's what
we use it for just goes
right so we've only been investing for a
very short time because
so what i would do is change your system
then you do not have a 90 000
income you have a hundred and two
thousand dollar income okay
counting bonuses yeah okay give or take
101
but somewhere right in there and so i
would be putting fifteen thousand
dollars a year
of your money systematically monthly
into retirement savings okay
and that that's a budgeting change for
you that's not that really doesn't
address the 43 000 but i would start
that immediately
i would not do what you're doing because
you might not get the bonus one year
and you need to you need to be in the
habit of steadily
investing 15 of your income
and the um so that that's the direction
i would go
now the um then the next step is do you
have children
one on the way in july then uh we might
use some of that 43 000 to set it aside
for kids college baby step
five and anything that's left beyond
that
i would put it on the house and uh and i
am also doing math
and part of the math i'm doing is data
that says that the typical millionaire
that we studied in the largest study of
millionaires ever done in north america
shows
that the typical millionaire has
paid off home and substantial money in
retirement
and what i just laid out for you will
get you there
substantial money in retirement 15 15
000 a year going into
retirement and uh then beyond that
uh uh you know you're putting the
the uh money toward every dollar above
that towards getting
the home paid off and the typical person
listening to the show doing our steps
pays off their home in seven to eight
years
the typical millionaire pays off their
home in about 10
years but people following this stuff
tend to be a little bit more intentional
a little bit more intense
and move in that direction so somewhere
in that 7-10 range
house is paid for but it won't be if you
keep screwing around and putting the 43
000 in investments because
quote unquote i did some math
which by the way was wrong
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five christopher is in dayton
ohio hi christopher welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
so uh i'll try and make a long story
short i am
uh divorced about three years ago and in
those three years i've been to court
uh my wife ex-wife has taken me to court
three times five times excuse me
so each time we go to court costs
anytime anywhere between ten thousand
and thirty thousand dollars
i was on baby step two just bumped down
to baby step one
um so we're rebuilding our thousand
dollar save or emergency fund
um we are ninety six thousand dollars in
debt i am remarried
uh we have a household income of a
hundred and twenty thousand and
why does she keep taking you to court
um i mean i don't want to speak early
over uh
i mean is this about kids or what's it
about
well in in her argument it's always
about the kids
um but she's um narcissists and
depression
so she lets that guide her ways even
though i keep winning in court
uh she keeps taking me back just finding
a different poll to do it
and um yeah so we're we're gearing up
for if it's around now that she's taking
me back
for the same reasons okay
i think you need an attorney that gets
on the offensive
not just the defensive because she's
abusing the court system it sounds like
she is and my wife and i have talked
about we don't even know if it's legal
to start doing like uh
harassment um type of uh legal action
towards her
you need an attorney to investigate that
you really do because this is
i mean i'm just listening to what you're
describing and and
you know people who are continually
doing that uh leave themselves open to a
lot type of liability there
and so the abuse of the court system is
a real thing attorneys can be sanctioned
for that
and um certainly individuals can just
filing frivolous lawsuits is not allowed
you know and so that's you know i keep
winning i keep winning and
she keeps looking for some angle so
anyway that that but anyway you so
you've got
96 000 in debt is that what you said
yes sir how much of that is attorney's
fees
um that is current attorney fees is
about 25
000 okay and what's the rest of it
the rest of it is from going through the
divorce um i
took on all the debt that we had at the
time and then
we you know it was like a snowball
effect in the wrong direction for us we
were dropping everything to be able to
pay for attorneys so then we accumulate
debt because we have
you know we could pay a lawyer we could
pay for food um i could lose my kids or
we could feed the kids kind of thing so
we ended up making
i wouldn't call them bad choices they
were just a noose around our neck
and we had to accumulate credit card
debt um so how much credit aren't there
sir uh credit card debt is sitting at
um i believe it's 22 000 right now
because that's 50 between those two
things that are associated with this
what's the other 50
and then there was a personal loan to
accumulate the uh the debt from
when the divorce first took place that's
currently sitting at 37 000
and then um the the rest of it is uh
like kids and braces and stuff like that
kids and braces for fifteen thousand
dollars
uh no no um if that doesn't equal up to
exactly fifteen
000 i'm trying to remember my dave randy
uh that's our
website what all of it is but most of it
is credit card and consolidation loan
yeah okay oh and family debt because
they helped me pay for lawyers as well
okay and you make 120 household income
now with your new wife
yes sir okay good all right um and
then your question at the end of this is
what
so right now we're projected to pay off
if nothing else happened
another 17 000 in debt by the end of the
year and we should be debt free by
uh mid august of 20 or excuse me mid um
2025 that's our goal and i guess our
question uh the wife and i were sitting
around talking and that is
what could we possibly do to better
protect ourselves so that
when we do get slapped in the face with
another
court um hearing we're not scrambling
for
twenty thousand dollars to to make it
happen our goal we're trying to beat
gazelles
and uh knock out this bed as fast as
possible but
every time we go to court it really
kicks us it beats us down
yeah yeah hey i don't know
uh it may be that you treat this like
it's a chronic situation
and say um you know if you had a an
illness
that cost you 20 000 a year that was
chronic
you would have to put that into your
budget and then above that
work on getting out of debt right
and so i i think you've got a chronic
legal problem for now
and you've got to continue so i put a
couple grand a month in the budget
set over in a separate savings account
only
only for legal fees potentially if you
and it might be that if it happens again
we're going to use those legal fees to
be
those attorneys fees to be offensive
okay okay so you would say you slow down
paying off the debt to build up a
account to build it
well because you're going because you're
you you have a very high probability
this is coming at you again
yes sir and so you know you've got to
get ready for it
i mean this is a christmas is coming in
december a lawsuit is coming from the
ex-wife these are predictable things
it is every time something good happens
in my life it seems to happen and i'm
not i'm not trying to be a black cloud
that's not my point my point is just
mathematically forecasting
we're just going to predict and if the
bad thing doesn't happen you've got the
money it didn't go anywhere
but you can't go buy a bass boat with it
then you got to use it for debt
absolutely so if for some reason she
decides to calm down
without being slapped into next week
with an attorney which
may be what has to happen um i mean
sometimes you just have to stand up and
fight
you know forward rather than backward
and i don't know i mean i don't know the
particulars of
your situation i'm not an attorney uh
but you know
there there is a benefit to going after
offensively some of these people that
misbehave using the court systems
well this is not working for your five
times in
this is not working so we can't you know
i mean like i would try something else
after this round or whatever it is you
know i i never suggest
heart i mean very very seldom does
suggest someone pick a fight
right but sometimes you have to finish
one yeah uh in order to
you know in order for it to be over yeah
it's not gonna be over until you finish
it
yeah you mean you've got to punch into
punch and punch and punch until it's
over
yeah and you just stand there and and
just you know and the problem being a
fight is
it it doesn't just uh hurt the person
that you're hitting it hurts you
yeah when you're hitting you're you're
you know if you're physically wearing a
fight your hands will get damaged you
know
uh you know boxers come out you know
they're damaged on both you know there's
no
no one gets out of these things
unscathed it's not like there's
one guy does all the hitting and one guy
doesn't right you know everybody gets
hit but the thing is if you're going to
go through all that
at least stick in it long enough to win
yeah where you don't have to fear this
every single year and just absolutely
defeat
the evil foe you know that's what you
and you have to take on that persona of
doing that and it's very difficult yeah
so it's emotional
because you can hear the emotional drain
on him oh my gosh like it's just never
and he's trying to he's
yeah but you're never going away
you know just go away i've had people in
my life like that
just go away just go go live your life
over there somewhere
just go away you know it but they can't
seem to do it so they they don't get it
no it's not just a financial drain it's
just that emotional drain to you know
the headache the strain on your marriage
your kids
it's it it's uh you know in your you go
from uh
you know being angry to sad to back and
forth and i'm just i'm so sorry yeah
sorry you've been been through that yeah
and and and it's you know it's
the problem is it's stealing both the
emotion the spirit and the money from
your future with your current wife
right that's the problem you're taking
your eyes off of good things that could
be done
instead you have to deal with this crap
yeah and this fight
yeah and uh hey been there myself know
how it is not in a divorce situation but
in other situations and you've just got
to
you just have to uh the bad actors
they have to be punished and you know
you don't have any way around it
uh you know i i don't set out to be
sheriff andy
but um but we'll finish it you know if
you're going to pick a fight and that's
that's the re that's where i'm coming
from because i've been in those
situations in
sadly in legal battles where you have to
become the aggressor
rather than even though you didn't start
the fight right in order to stop it
that's how it works all right open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five christy wright ramsey
personality is my
co-host james childs is our producer
kelly daniels our associate producer and
phone screener
i am dave ramsey and we'll be back
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsay call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice christie
wright ramsay personality is my co-host
this hour this day open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five you can hear her on
the christy wright show
where faith meets personal development
so you can have a bigger faith and a
better life
you get the encouragement you want with
the tough love truth you need
to connect with god take control of your
life and enjoy your life
new episodes every tuesday on youtube
and anywhere you listen to podcasts the
christy
wright show open phones triple eight
eight two five
five two two five jeff's in daytona
beach hi jeff how are you
i'm doing well sir how are you doing
real happy to be on the on the phone
with you
you too sir how can we help so i have a
question
my wife and i are are looking to install
a pool in our backyard and
i uh i know your your thoughts on on
pools and
and getting refinancing to use the money
for that but
just a little bit about my wife and i
have lived very financially responsible
we have no debt cars are paid off we
have college funds for the kids
we maxed out both roth iras we're also
both pension employees
with the city here so we have a pension
to look forward to and we have deferred
comp
um we bought our we currently owe 134
on our home our interest rate is 4.125
what do you do what do you need you're
doing great man i'm talking you're doing
wonderful i know yes yeah
how can i help so we are wanting to
install a pool in our backyard we have
two young kids
we are in what we consider our forever
homes and we are wanting to refinance
the house
and pull sixty thousand dollars out of
the house
to install the pool you wanna put a
sixty thousand dollar house in a hundred
sixty thousand dollar pool and 130 000
house
so no we only owe 130 oh i'm sorry
what's the house worth what's the house
worth
one third i'm sorry 330.
yeah the new rate we could get would be
two point three seven
five i said that's an expensive pool
yeah oh yeah sixty thousand dollars is
an expensive pool that's
uh that's that's my wife's feeling and
that's a that's uh
it is yeah it's hard doing you're the
one calling jeff
i i know it it
it would be a very nice pool and i know
it's expensive but like i said we are
not planning on on going anywhere
at least until the kids are through high
school so that's about another 13 years
you know for the youngest one
okay um well what you're
very clearly describing over and over
and over again
and you've said it six different ways is
that you know this is an irresponsible
bad idea
yeah but you're trying you're but you're
trying to make me think it's okay
so that so that you're going to think
it's okay so that they will say
you're you're on to me i mean it's just
it's
um okay let's walk through it so number
one i'm not against fun
number two you have done a great job
with your finances congratulations
number three you have a clue where you
are you know exactly what's going on
you're not a wandering generality you're
not
out of control you're you're very
systematized you've been
very uh beautifully done
you've told me your numbers you're not
you're not guessing you know exactly
where you are so you have a lot of
positive things going on
and and then you have this uh your
stomach is in your throat because you're
getting ready to pay
too much for a pool for a 330 000
house it doesn't make sense to put that
nice a pool on a house that
expense meaning you would never recoup
it
ever you're you're over building the
neighborhood you have to be by
definition
even if there's pools all up and down
your street they're not sixty thousand
dollar pools and three hundred thousand
dollar houses
people don't do that that is true okay
so number one you know you're spending
too much number two you're borrowing
money to buy a fun
toy yes and you know that that's not
unwise
and um you called the guy that was would
tell you both of those things right i
mean
what what do you want how can i help you
could i could i run something by you you
think it's going to change my mind
i don't know
i try that technique jeff with my
husband all the time well let me just
give you one more
all right let's try let's try it let's
try it you're a good sport jeff let's
try it for fun here
so my wife and i we purchased the home
we've been in the home about six years
we purchased it for a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars
it has appraised quite a bit i i
understand
so the new if we were to refinance
um at a lower rate of 2.37 we would have
that
the the mathematic equation you give out
we would with the closing cost which is
about nine thousand dollars we would
cover that in about three years
we're going to be in the home for at
least i'd say at least 10 to 15 years
and with the refinance we're only
refinancing at 210
uh 210 000 which is still substantially
less than what all the homes and i
think it's going to make you bankrupt
okay yeah
i don't think you're going to go out of
business because of this
i don't think you're going to completely
you know get a divorce because of
financial stress
that's not that's not what i'm saying
i'm saying
a you're borrowing money to buy a toy
sure even though you figured out some
bass awkward sophisticated way to make
it sound okay but you're still borrowing
money to buy a toy
and you're over building your
neighborhood
both okay so if you want to do if you
want to
do one if you want to do one of those
overbuild the neighborhood
okay so don't but don't borrow the money
to do it
gotcha so i and i so i
i if i woke up in your shoes i would do
one of two things
uh and is do you have any money to put
towards this project
we would we have twenty thousand dollars
that we would put uh
towards but the way pools are built ever
i mean it's such a hot commodity here in
the state of florida right now that
they're putting an 80 pooling oh jeff
you're in more trouble now
oh it's a sixty thousand dollar pool oh
okay so you're borrowing
you're willing to borrow forty yes sir
i'm sorry
okay no i'm misunderstood i'm
misunderstood okay so you got twenty
so if you and what's your household
income
about 110 000 phenomenal okay
i would project that based on the fact
that you two actually have done
so good until we got to this
conversation with your finances
that the two of you could add another 20
000 to this 20 000
very quickly and pay cash for a 40 000
pool if dave and sharon ramsey were in
your shoes
that's exactly what we would do yes sir
i'm going to tell my wife we're going to
have to eliminate sushi sunday
and that's that big no more it's up to
you it's not a lemonade it's trade
we're trading it for a pool you eat a
lot of sushi apparently but
i was waiting for that but but your
trade you know you're going to eliminate
some lifestyle to get the pool that's
what dave and sharon ramsey would do
we've but we've got some nice toys in
our life and i remember
the first time we bought a toy we bought
a little bitty dinky butt house on the
lake for a hundred thousand dollars and
we thought it was the
oh god we just bought a second house
we're like rich people or something we
have two houses
it was a hundred thousand hundred three
thousand dollars
and uh but we pay cash for it and we've
never regretted it
we've never regretted on a lake house
because we pay cash for our toys
and they don't come back to bite you in
the butt later this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
i'm proud of my state of tennessee
and one of the greatest things about our
state has been that we have had a
great run of incredible governors
at least the last two anyway and
governor bill haslam was a governor here
for two terms
currently governor bill lee is our
governor in tennessee and uh
bill and i became friends during that
time christie's wife as well
and he was an incredible incredible
governor and
uh um incredible uh
not politician but statesman is a better
word and has written a brand new book
i i went to donald miller's house the
other night with a bunch of folks in our
area here that were friends of both of
ours bills in mind and
got to hear a little bit of the reading
from it and the background on it it's
called faithful
presence the promise and the peril
of faith in the public square bill and i
are both christians and it is messy when
you
once you say you're a christian someone
disagrees with you immediately you're a
fake christian
immediately uh someone's got something
to say about that but
uh you know how you can uh act out your
faith
in the public square uh
bill comes from the pilot oil family his
daddy is a
started pilot oil and his brother owns
the cleveland browns
and uh if i got that right you got it
right okay and uh make sure i say the
right thing jimmy
big jim will get me jimmy will get me
for sure you get a quick call but yeah
i'll get i'll get uh big jim would get
on me i don't want big jim after
but uh big university of tennessee fans
as well and alumni like we are
and uh uh generosity in that direction
so
a little bit of background there so bill
you and i when you uh
were running for governor the first time
uh with your background coming from a
family of means
we're sitting you and chrissy and i and
sharon were sitting on our back deck
remember
kind of getting to know each other right
right a little bit and i asked you a
question i said
why would you take this job because it
doesn't pay
that much in comparison to other things
you could have done and have done in
your life
and you come from a family of means you
didn't it's not something you needed
financially and you didn't need the
power you didn't need any of that
why would you why would you want that
job it's kind of what i said you
remember that
i do i remember the conversation well
and it was an honest question because i
just
couldn't envision it yeah well first of
all you talked about the success of
tennessee and
ramsey and ramsey solutions is part of
that story i've i got to stand here
where we are now when it was a field
um and to see what you have done to see
what you've done with the place as we
say around tennessee is impressive so
first of all let me just dip it was with
your help as well no
cool state was a big help too so why do
i run
you know we all find different ways to
serve right you've been able to change
thousands and hundreds of thousands
millions of people's lives by giving
them some insight into financial
um a better financial way to carry out
their lives
government serves a lot of different
people and it makes it different who
governs matters
and for me it just felt like a huge
opportunity to serve and i know it
sounds kind of corny
but it felt like for me the way to to
change more lives
for the better than anything else i
could do well and i
also remember you saying you felt like
god told you to
i did it well and it was a call a
spiritual call as chrissy would would
always remind me during the campaign
campaigns aren't really fun aren't much
fun
and she'd say okay you you are called to
run the election will decide if you're
called to serve
so there was always a whole lot of well
we'll see well thanks for watching the
wife there yeah
but she was right and so we really did
feel that way and so if you do feel that
way then
then you do it differently you don't do
it uh with you know your own
your own ends in mind bill haslam former
governor of the state of tennessee the
book is faithful presence the promise
and the peril
of faith in the public square so this
your first book
why write a book about this subject and
why now
you know uh it is my first book it might
might be my only
you know some people like you have
enough to cover a lot of books this
might you know i only have enough for
one problem
but here's why you know it's no secret
the country's at each other's throats
uh and everybody talks about the
polarization and we're not just that but
we're mad
um and we're not just mad but we think
the other side has bad motives the
question is what are we gonna do about
it well
jesus was pretty clear in in scripture
when something was wrong he always
started with us the religious types uh
and he said hey if the meat's gone bad
it's not
the er it's not the meat's fault it's
the salt's fault the salt's not doing
its job and so
this is a call to all of us who say that
we want to follow jesus
and then others who don't but want to
know the role of faith in the public
square to say
what role could we have in being light
in the darkness and being sought to meet
and changing the tone of the
conversation
politics uh i you know anytime you get
up in the spotlight like i have been for
many years
you get the haters and you get the and
you get the uh people who
believe you can do anything which both
are wrong right and um
but the uh uh you know you ought to run
for office and i immediately just about
no no i have a physical reaction
it it sounds so exhausting would be
balanced we know that
that's true and there will be a lot of
angry people but yeah
but uh it's messy it's exhausting it's
sometimes ineffective why should we even
care about politics
well you know it says in scripture that
god causes the the sun to fall on the
just and the unjust the rain on the
righteous and the unrighteo
he cares about the common good and this
is a way that that
government impacts what we do and how
life works and
again think about your principles so
tennessee's actually lived that way
we've lived as a fiscally responsible
state because of that we can keep taxes
low we can attract businesses to come
here
it matters the decisions you make and
that affects again
millions of people uh because of that so
um
one of the reasons i wrote the book is i
don't want people to say oh a pox on
both your houses i'm tired of all the
argument
i'm not going to pay any attention
because that's the wrong response to the
current situation
right the the only way to fix it is
engage i stand back and throw grenades
doesn't do it
it's never it's never worked and by the
way it's never changed anybody's mind
either
yeah that's true that's true
so bill lee's been in office
two years a little bit more about two
and a half years so you know so you've
been so
the last 10 plus years right we've been
having these conversations
um it feels like to me
that it's gotten a lot nastier
during that 10 years nationally yeah i
don't think it just feels like it has
and all the data would show you that
that it's we've gone from disagreeing to
think the other side
has bad motives and even being
contemptuous of the other side
yeah how do we get in this mess i think
there's several things number one
we've always been a little i mean we've
always been you know it's always been
partisan you know our the founders
got literally gotten duels with each
other uh so
so we shouldn't kid ourselves and say oh
this is new but i think secondly
the world's different and so with social
media
you can hide behind the anonymity of the
internet as you know and people can say
whatever they want about you
keyboard keyboard courage the keyboard i
love that i'm stealing that
uh people can have keyboard courage
people can
uh people can in politics can say well
i can just go be a social media star i
don't really have to solve problems so
it's like i'm going to play a senator on
tv i'm not going to really be one in
terms of solving problems and
i think the fact that folks can choose
their own news and how they get it we
we just tend to dig further deeper into
our own
beliefs and not take any time at all to
listen to
is there a better way to do this yeah
the ability to sit down and calmly
listen to the other side
is a lost art it really is and somehow
we think that if we yell at the other
side we're going to change their mind
and that's
changed nobody's mind ever doesn't you
know i'm going to get mad and call you
names
and on twitter and that's going to make
you feel better yeah
and i'm going to vote your way now yeah
exactly yeah exactly
faithful presence is the book the
promise and the peril
of faith in the public square former
governor of the state of tennessee
two terms bill haslam what strengths and
gifts
if people of faith come to the public
square should they be bringing well you
think about one of those that we should
bring is
people always deciding am i going to be
a person of truth or a person of love
and we're supposed to be both
we're supposed to understand that it's
you know speak the truth with love we're
supposed to people think we either have
to choose mercy
or choose justice and we understand it's
both i mean we actually have a god that
lived out
mercy and justice at the same time uh
and so we have a picture of that the
other
advantage we have is we know we're
broken imperfect people that's part of
the definition of being
uh being a follower of jesus well if we
are that
then by definition we know we have the
capacity to be wrong too
that's not a bad place to start the
discussion yeah and that makes you a
listener
i hope so love your spirit love your
humility
appreciate your friendship you too you
and sharon have
become great friends thanks governor
bill haslam
former governor of the state of
tennessee check this book out guys it's
life-changing and it's really needed in
the marketplace right now
faithful presence the promise and the
peril of faith
in the public square this is the ramsay
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight
two five five two two five in las vegas
andrew and shanae are with us it says on
my screen you guys are
debt free congratulations thank you
how much did you pay off seventy eight
thousand
five hundred and sixty four dollars good
for you awesome and how long did this
take you
364 days
okay there we go the one year minus a
day mark okay
and your range of income during that
time
um our range of income started about
ninety seven thousand four hundred and
ten
and then we finished at um one hundred
and forty eight thousand nine
or eight hundred and forty wow what do
you guys do for a living
i'm a police officer and i'm the office
manager of a dental office
how did you get your income up so far in
one year
um i worked over 901 hours of overtime
wow wow great place to go when you're
broke to work huh
way to go andrew man i bet you're happy
this is over
yeah the wife's pretty happy too she has
help with kids now yeah
absolutely she was a single mom for a
year so uh
that's what my wife said yeah so uh what
kind of debt was your 79 000
uh it ranged from we had a
personal loan for 42 000 we had credit
cards we had cars and we had a 30
400 vacuum cleaner of course
yeah what well it does everything
[Music]
or not but yeah so what was the 42 000
personal loan what was that um so
we have two children and um i was a
stay-at-home mom
um for about almost three years and
during that time
we thought it was going to be a good
idea to consolidate
um a car payment and credit cards into a
consolidation loan
and we were kind of you know at that
time we didn't know a whole lot about
paying off debt and stuff and we thought
at that time that was going to be our
best option
and then when my daughter was born um
she had a lot of medical problems and so
we got behind on a payment
and it kind of just downhill from there
yeah i got you
okay yeah that thing they're trying to
borrow your way out of debt
lots of folks have tried that one you're
not the only one way to go
i'm so proud of you guys what started
this uh this debt snowball this lit your
fuse because you guys went
nuts i mean you were going after it 901
hours of overtime
what started all this a year ago um so i
had gone to a training
with a co-worker and during the training
uh
finances had got brought up and he was
saying that he was getting ready to pay
cash for a million dollar home
and i looked at him and i said how is
that possible i mean you have the same
job
we're the same age like how how are you
doing this
and he grew up uh in a ramsey household
and so he started telling me about it
and i spent a couple more days away from
the family at the training just looking
this stuff up
came home told the wife about it and we
were just
right then and there we started and we
had kind of talked about actually
the options of going bankrupt after that
consolidation loan
like went to collections and stuff
because we were having all those medical
problems with my daughter
um and so when he came home and was
talking about that
it was like well we either do this or we
file bankrupt because we're
not really sure what to do and we were
so young that bankruptcy didn't
obviously sound too enticing so this was
the only other option we had and it
sounded like the best thing and
we kind of just went full force yeah you
sure did
so how did you plug into us um
when we were at the training he told me
your name
so and then my mom had told me about you
when i was in high school and something
but i you don't listen to your mom when
you're a teenager yeah
and so once i saw someone my own age
living that way
is when we started i started listening
to the podcast oh the podcast okay
every single day i've i have all of the
books the audiobooks that i've listened
to
at least once a month yeah it's just we
went crazy on it
okay all right cool and so the budgeting
and the whole process so what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is
sticking to a budget yeah inconsistency
i mean like it's hard and
you know you especially when you have
people um you know that you're friends
with or family that are kind of like oh
well you know and they live in like the
debt lifestyle and they're okay with
credit cards and they're okay well
i want the points you know i want this
and so you know you have those people
that kind of tell you what you're doing
is silly and stuff and
um so my my opinion is making sure that
you're not
listening to that because there is a lot
of people that will try and tell you
um you know their other ways are better
and so
just consistency and really knowing what
your goals are
and keeping keeping your goals in focus
because otherwise people
really do try to talk you out of it yeah
there's a lot of naysayers and it's just
because they don't have hope a lot of
times
right and uh but who were your best
cheerleaders
um oh man that stuff we had
i think each other honestly
we had some friends outside but me and
her one of us would start to feel a
little discouraged or something like
that and the other one would
be like hey knock that off like we got
this let's do this
and so we just worked together as a team
uh it was probably the best thing but we
had some friends that stuck by
yeah what kept you motivated i know a
year is pretty fast for you guys to do
this but there had to be some some of
those times where you were getting
discouraged would you
what did you guys tell each other would
you keep in mind to be able to stick
with it
i would say it was the thing that dave
has is
live like no one else so later you can
live and give like no one else so we
figured
if we took a year away from being able
to do all the fun things
and just really put our heads to it we
would have a lifetime of being able to
do the fun thing
that's awesome and we have a four and a
six year old and
so i think that was a lot of it too
because um
i really want to be able to you know
send them to school and not have
if that's what they choose to do and not
have to have a lot of financial things
i know i grew up um you know with a lot
of hard like financial situations and
i don't want that for my children um
we've taught our
we've taught our kids um this kind of
thing and like even my six-year-old he
goes out and he gets a job
cleaning up dog poop for friends and
they pay him and we teach him how to
like
you know spend save and give so
trying to show them a good way of living
with a lot of motivation as well just
trying to make sure that they can see
you know that you have to work hard in
order to
live freely later that's awesome so your
friend
andrew who paid cash at your age for a
million dollar house
you know that that's your son right i
really hope so yeah he's growing up in a
ramsey house
that's right he's growing up in a house
where mom and dad are living on less
than they make mom and dad don't borrow
money mom and dad know how to work their
butts off
and you're teaching him how to work you
know
i mean it would do a lot of america good
if at some point their kid had picked up
poop for money
it could change this country it really
could yes
80 bucks a month going house to house
yeah that's awesome wow
that's awesome wow this kid's an
entrepreneur
uh no ken no pun intended but yeah
wow you guys this is incredible i'm so
so proud of you guys
very very well done absolutely
incredible
uh so here's the deal we got a copy of
the legacy journey for you
that's uh the book about what happens
now the live like no one else part
now that you've done it and the legacy
that we're just talking about with your
kids
and we've also got a copy of the total
money makeover for you to take and give
to someone
because now andrew you're going to be
that friend that runs into somebody and
starts their journey
and that's how this works so paying it
forward so again we're just so proud of
you guys
very very well done all right it's
andrew
and shanae 79 000
paid off in 364 days with 901 hours of
overtime
making 97 to 148 they are free
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
amazing you know it's not hard to work
that hard when you can see the light at
the end of the tunnel that's right
and you can see that you're getting
there yes i love that visual of how you
said that's going to be your sun like oh
you forecast into the future the ripple
effect of this decision
with that next generation and beyond
that that's incredible change your
family tree baby
you can do it and i'm talking to you
yeah you
you thought you were just in the car
listing the radio now i'm talking to you
you need to change your family tree
it's in your power to do it now do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
have you ever made a dumb decision with
zeroes on the end
because you didn't do your research yeah
me too
sometimes we all make choices dumb
choices based on feelings or opinions
and if you do something like that when
you're buying a house
yeah and this real estate market
feelings are
not your friend facts
are your friend because everybody's
going bonkers out there
check your facts find out what you can
actually afford
research what's really trending in home
prices talk to reputable real estate
agents
in your area this is not amateur hour
where mark warehouses are getting
multiple offers
do not let a monkey sell your house and
a monkey can get a real estate license
and they sell two houses and then you've
listed your highest
most expensive property asset with
someone who doesn't know what the flip
they're doing
get the facts know what you're getting
into
and get a pro in your corner go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent you can plug in with one of our
elps our endorsed
local providers that we have vetted
their high octane high protein
the top real estate agents in the nation
ramsey solutions dot com
slash agent that's how this works
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five
two two five tina is in austin texas
hi tina welcome to the ramsay show thank
you for having me and listening
to your podcast a lot well thank you and
um
i just it's kind of like jeff your
earlier caller i feel like i'm pretty
frugal i'm really good with my money
um but i wanted to make sure i'm on the
right track and
i feel really stressed when i'm spending
my money
um when or when i'm using my money for
myself when it's a gift or a donation no
problem anybody check
but then when it comes to me i get
really nervous um
grocery store i don't want to binge on
the five dollar chocolate or whatever
right i just want to make sure i'm the
right path of
um savings uh
so i'm on baby step number six um paying
off my mortgage
i feel like i've done a really good job
with everything else i skipped number
five i don't have any kids
um and thanks to the podcast i got
really good so intense during
um the pandemic and i paid off my car
this is pretty
dave ramsey i've heard about you for ten
years but i never really read the book
how can i help today how sorry how can i
help today
so i wanted to make sure that i was on
the right path for um
um when i paid off the mortgage i have
two different homes one's a rental under
an llc
and one's my home home and then you
always talk about paying that off
as soon as possible i wanted to see
which one should i pay off first
um do i go get so intense and paying
those off
and or do i just kind of loosen up a
little bit
generally speaking what we do is if
they're similar
in payoff balance i'd pay off your home
first uh but if you have a tiny little
rental mortgage you want to just reach
over knock it out and then come back to
the home
uh that's okay too we're going to get
both of them eventually
agreed yes okay so how much is owed on
each
um i owe 61 205 on the rental
with five years left and then 170
313 with 11 years left and your income
is what
uh taxable income is 73. 5 000. that's
how much you're getting 72 000
taxable income 73. 73. 73 000
okay all right the w2 is a 97
yeah okay so you know the rental is
substantially smaller
in balance yes and if you wanted to push
it up front you can
uh that would be a reason to push it up
front i always
want to cheat towards the residents
because of risk management and all that
means is
in an absolute horrible worst case
scenario
if you were going to lose one to
foreclosure you'd want to lose the
rental
not your home and so getting rid of the
the place where you lay your head down
at night
having no mortgage releases you in the
spirit
releases your spirituals you know self a
lot and then because of you know the
rental property and whatever we can lose
it or we can sell it and it's no big
deal
but where you live gives you an extra
dose of peace when it is paid off
and so i tend to cheat towards that so
that's a reason to put it first
but the rental is very small so you can
knock it out pretty fast if you get
after it right
right so either one is okay in this case
but that's the way i look at it
that's the two things i look at is it
and so if you owed
150 on the rental and 170 on your house
i'd say go to your house
because of what i was describing earlier
but because your rental is so small
if you want to go over there first you
can do either one
you know again you know we're only 230
000
from being completely free and that's
pretty cool
she's done a great job yeah it's amazing
it's always good when the question is
either option is a good one that's the
answer yeah you know
you're in a good spot because you've
done really well yeah you've done real
smart
and uh when both answers are smart quite
answers right
yeah that's a that that's a lot better
than both answers for dumb answers
yeah i've been there too i've done both
uh
joey's in hattiesburg hi joey how are
you
hi dave how are you doing today better
than i deserve what's up
well i am 20 years old i own two
businesses one is a startup
the other has been running for about
three years um
for the one that's been running i owe
176
000 um on the business um
104 of that is owner finance loan um 63
of it
is through a bank and then 9k is minor
debt
well i know the general rule is never to
take out of an ira
however i'm hoping that you'll give me
permission for an exception
um i've got a cd for 64 000 and an
inherited ira for 700 i'm sorry
79 000. not bad okay the inherited ira
is 79 and the cds how much
64 000. okay all right
and the owner finance loan the one for
104k
said if i paid in full they would take
10 percent off um
meaning i would save um ten thousand
four hundred dollars on principal
and another seventeen thousand in
interest
and my idea is to use that cd put that
towards it and take the other
thirty thousand dollars 000 ira yeah an
inherited ira i would do that
when did you get the inherited ira
oh um three years ago for my father okay
i'm sorry sorry for your loss there um
yeah and where did the cd come from same
thing
same thing um it was life insurance okay
and what kind of business are you
running at 20 years old that you won 170
000
in debt for um it's a vending machine
business it started out as 260 000.
and i've been able to get it down to
there you're making money
um yes to be fair during corona it was
barely paying for itself but
nevertheless paying for itself how much
do you make a month gross right now
gross i mean it varies from month month
but
on average 8k
it's my day yeah okay
so you're making like 30 grand a year
profit
as of right now yes um but i've had
that's because a lot of my business
taken away i'm regaining it back
um now that kovis is coming to an end
in mississippi
absolutely okay yeah i would have
thought it would be back
mississippi's open it is
but like the schools which is more than
half of my business
oh okay all right all right
that does explain it okay and now you're
out for the summer
exactly that's the reason my average is
so low yeah okay
all right that's helpful because i'm
just afraid for you these are these
numbers scare the crap out of me and
here's
here's the thing yes i would to answer
your question yes i would do this i
would take the cd
and enough out of the inherited and pay
the loan off i would also try to
negotiate down more than a 10
discount because they probably need the
cash
offer them 20 off and just see what they
say all they can do say no all we'll do
is 10
right so just say i'm having to cash out
my dad's
when he passed away inherited ira and
it's making me feel funny i'll do this
if you'll do 20
throw a little emotion in there see what
you can get them to do
and uh here's the thing i want you to
walk away with don't do this again
you won't have another one of these
shots to clean up this mess
next time you get ready to grow a
business or buy a business you pay cash
for it
don't do this again i'm scared
for where you were you're getting a
one-way ticket out don't you go back
that wasn't unclear was it no you you
covered it well
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host christy wright ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five kai is with us in
orlando is it k or kai kai
kai cool how can we help so i'm i'll be
on baby step
two and i'm working an extra job where
i'm an independent contractor
and i think i can pay off my debt in way
before next tax season certainly by the
end of this year
should i set aside taxes still or should
i should i wait till later to
get rid of those taxes ready yeah you're
going to want to go ahead and set those
aside go ahead and plan for them
do you know you have projections of what
you're what you're planning to do this
fall
uh yes so um so it's just an
it's an actual a couple hundred dollars
a week but uh it's it's my second
it's gonna be third job um and my total
uh debt is seven thousand six hundred
dollars what do you make uh not counting
this job
uh that'd be about 32 000 i'm just i'm
getting actually getting ready to start
the job next week
okay oh cool cool well
here's the here's the tech you're just
out of college
yes sir okay cool here's what we're the
proper way to do this
is to file quarterly estimates
on the profits of your business
when you're an independent subcontractor
you're technically running a business
you have a sole proprietorship
okay my guess is you don't have any
expenses associated with the business
that are deductible do you
i guess not other than maybe gas and
mileage
okay are you what are you driving like
uber each or something
uh yeah it's a grocery delivery okay
all right yeah you will have some
deductions there you'll want to keep
track of all that
yeah you want to keep track you can
either write off uh
the mileage by the irs guideline or you
can write off
the expenses associated with the car one
of the two
usually in your case the mileage is
going to be a better way
okay so you have a deduction so let's
say that
um your miles amount to 50
a week that you can write off and you
make 200
a week your profit would be 150 then
you're following me
yes sir so what i would tell you to do
is this number one
um uh you can probably just jump online
and look and see what the irs is
allowing per mile and just keep up with
your mileage
keep a log book of your miles okay
and you can do it electronically you can
do it in an old-fashioned log book if
you want to
either one but you need to keep up with
it in case they question you someday you
need to have the records
that questioning you is called an audit
okay
so i don't think that'll happen but but
you don't want to get burned on this
so now so you take the my the allowable
rate per mile times the mile you drive
and deduct that
as an expense and then
once a quarter you're supposed to file a
quarterly estimate
it's a one-page thing it's very easy to
do with the irs
and it amounts to all of the money you
made at the grocery delivery
in this case minus the deduction you're
taking for all the miles during that
quarter
that three month period of time okay
the difference is called profit what you
brought in minus the miles is your
profit you following me
yes times your tax rate and you're going
to send them a check for that amount
once a quarter on your taxes and so
i don't want you to wait until next year
to pay your taxes
because you're going to get penalized
possibly
for not paying them on time because
you're supposed to do it once a quarter
technically
and then when someone does that when
someone pays quarterly when they
actually comes around a tax time aren't
they just kind of reconciling the
difference at that point it's just so
much simpler
on you as well you won't oh if you do it
properly you won't owe any taxes on this
portion of your income next uh spring
when you file your taxes
okay and i don't want that to sneak up
on you and hit you in the back of the
head later because we said oh don't
worry about taxes do that later
no yeah that'll get you burnt right
there man
so just go ahead and stay stay ahead of
the game the last snake you want to play
with
is the irs snake it bites
and day for clarification for anybody
listening right now that is in a similar
situation
don't you recommend percent if you're
not sure what your tax rate is yep
twenty-five percent set aside out of
your income yeah so as you're making it
through that three-month period of time
you can kind of be doing this
calculation
i'm going to take the mileage off and 25
of the difference i'm going to set aside
in a savings account to be ready to pay
those quarterly estimates yep
and that's that way you'll have the
money when the quarterly estimate comes
up
because it's you and i have with
business boutique and with entree
leadership we have talked to
thousands of people who got themselves
in serious tax trouble
they do not pay quarterly taxes they
don't even know they need to pay them
and they don't really
realize the benefit to themselves if
they do of just setting aside that
as you get the income as you get the
revenue that you set aside that twenty
five
fourth of your profit needs to be set
aside on a separate savings account
it's just for taxes don't touch it it's
it's tax money you're withholding on
yourself
is all you're doing you're just doing
what they supposedly do for you with
withholding they might
sell them to it right there you go open
phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five cole
is with us in utah hi cole welcome to
the ramsey show
hey dave and christy uh thanks for
taking my call i'm very excited
sure what's going on yeah so
i'm in an interesting situation i
started a
i have a stable job as a full-time
fireman in vegas
i live in utah and i started a side gig
to
help me to stay home more to supplement
some income and now that income has
grown and the problem i'm having is i
work 100 hours a week
about and i have three babies at home
and i want to be home more so i'm trying
to figure out if
i should step away from my stable job
and
lose that sense of security and stick
with a commission-based job or what
that's going to look like
how far away from vegas do you live
it takes me about two and a half hours
to get to my fire station from my house
i don't understand that you do you do
this once
a day four days a week no so
i work two days on and four days off so
i do a 48 hour
yeah schedule so i drive down once or
twice a week
and then i come back and then on your
off days you have a side gig that's
kicking butt
yeah i'm a real estate agent so i
started doing that and
it took my income from just fire about
70 and now i'm doing
over 300. okay
uh now quit
now driving yesterday a long time ago
why do you have to think about it what
is the question
it's i know the market is hot now and
it's doing well as an agent but
if it's gonna slow down and my income
could drop
back down low and the security
well if i step away from the fire job
on the fire department i lose that that
stability and that stable income
yeah you lose five hour commutes and
you're we see your three small children
dude you should have quit like 30 years
ago
wow like by the end of the week you're
not a fireman anymore
that's it you have no life
go get you a life wow you are not afraid
of hard work though
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
summer's almost here but that does not
mean you can take a vacation from your
money goals
motivation to stay in tents can go away
i understand but especially when you
want that beach trip or
this kind of stuff the old vacation uh
waves in front of you and you go stop
your whining
listen if you live like no one else
later you can live and give like no one
else if you will vacate
like no one else meaning not at all
later you can vacate like no one else
meaning anywhere
you want to go baby and there's some
cool places in this world you ought to
be able to
you ought to be rich enough to go see
but you're not going to get there if you
keep spending money like you're in
congress
so it's time to straighten up a ramsey
plus membership
gives you our best digital money course
financial peace university all of our
digital money courses are there
smart money smart kids know yourself
know your money they're all in there
legacy journey all the tools like the
every dollar
premium the world's best budgeting app
all of this helps you keep
moving forward it's about getting small
wins that lead to big results
your goals are worth working for all
year
long stay motivated
with a free trial of ramsey plus text
trial 233 789
that's trial two three three
seven
thanks for joining us america we are
glad you are here
christy it's worth going back to our
firemen for a minute yeah okay
seventy thousand dollars a year two and
a half hours each way commute
but he made three hundred thousand in
real estate she had a 370 thousand
dollar income three little kids at home
he's working 100 hours a week
in in our minds it was and in most of
our list
most of you listening you were going why
in this guy quit already why in the
world is he still
doing this fire thing and what that says
is this guy is tremendously
driven by a need for security
and he falsely believes that the fire
fireman's job is more secure than the
real estate jobs yeah and that's a
falsehood
which is interesting too because i've
noticed a pattern where we've had some
similar calls not the same question
where it's well when is it okay to do
this and it's like it was okay
ten years ago but it's that we hold on
there's this fear that keeps us trapped
in some idea that
that we we're not there we don't have
enough the what if i lose my job i've
heard you ask people well
how stable is your job they're like oh i
don't know something could happen but
it's a very stable job they've been
there for
20 years and the industry's secure and
and so it's just interesting how fear i
feel like is this shadow
that haunts us and because we never
really pin it down and define us it can
always torment us like what if what if
what if but the scenarios are not even
remotely probable they're not realistic
well and when it comes to your income
it can be the tapes that were played in
your house when you were growing up
in the sense of always get a good job
and the definition of a good job
is that it that it's always going to pay
yeah
it's a steady work it's steady it's in
its income you can count on
and versus being self-employed or
straight commission yeah which is an
unstable job right
but it's not necessarily an unstable
income what's interesting though is i'm
curious have you seen a correlation
between
uh preference in terms of like salary
commission you know however it's
structured
by personality style because like no i
think i think it's just a
uh it would be back to rachel's book
know yourself know your money it's
abundance versus scarcity or
it's um you know we all have one of
those
uh but the the scarcity mentality i
would just go with that as an example
and that could be any personality style
but it usually would go back to your uh
the way you were brought up the
household you grew up in
and um and you will either react
way to the opposite of the way you grew
up or you'll try to do the same thing
again
one of the two and but very seldom just
in the middle yeah
until you look up and you go wait a
minute the way i was brought up is
what's influencing this not the facts
feelings are not facts yeah and and so
uh
here's an example okay if you made 300
000
in a white hot real estate market if the
real estate market cools off you've done
enough transactions you know how to do a
transaction
you ought to you ought to it's logical
the facts would indicate that the
chances of you making
uh le you know one-third
of what you used to make or greater
is very high based on your track record
right
and how long you've been doing this
you've been doing it longer you have
word of mouth you have referrals there's
there's not enough transactions that if
you if you didn't make 300 but the
market cooled off and you only made 100
but you used to make 70
as a fireman you still came out ahead so
that it ought to give you
all kinds of emotional breathing room to
be able to quit the quote-unquote
steady job but here's the problem people
think that where they work
is how what makes it steady and it's not
your talent and ability to
land a job doing something is what makes
is the only thing that gives you
stability and so if you're a high
quality salesperson
you can always land a job in doing sales
always
in any marketplace at any time now you
may have to change
you might you might be doing medical
devices and later you might be doing
cars
or later you'd be doing cars unless
you're doing medical devices or
pharmaceuticals i don't care
but a salesperson that knows how to sell
and has worked on straight commission
and knows how to
has a high relational iq regardless of
the personality type
has a proven track record you're only as
secure
as your own ability the fact that
the that it's the government that pays
the firemen
makes you secure no what makes you
secure is
you you have the ability to leave the
cave kill something and drag it home and
it's proven
that's where your security comes from
and and so
but and you have to use those as dr john
deloney would say we use facts are our
friends and the way we
overcome trauma is uh we calm down and
we deal with
facts not the emotions of the situation
and i think that releases people to go
live their dreams then
yeah it's interesting too because it's
when you break it down like that it
helps people see oh i had some beliefs
about stable versus unstable
job that had nothing to do with what the
company is or where the money comes from
we've seen something similar
when it comes to non-profit or
for-profit status and building a
business so i work with a lot of
business owners
and they say well i want to i want to
structure my business as non-profit
because i wanted to somehow be holy and
do work that matters because
as if the irs designation is somehow the
holiness factor and so we'll have i will
attach ideas
to statuses especially in relation to
government that are not actually
accurate
at all but i have a friend that owns a
small business that has grown year over
year over year over year
for 20 years he's not made his personal
income
out of that business that he paid taxes
on for the last 20 years has not been
under a million dollars a year
that's incredible yeah that's incredible
yeah but
and so is his income
stable yes for 20
years yes yeah you know but it's all but
but cove had affected it yeah
cloven could have dr you know could have
dried up his market could have done
but is his income stable yes yeah it's
an income statement it's got 20 years
right of being able to do this it wasn't
one time right
it wasn't just not this young man here
was he it was one time and it is
just during white ochovid and so forth
but he's out there still getting stuff
done he's
there's a lot of real estate agents who
haven't even been able to figure out how
to sell a house in this mess which means
you really do need to get out of the
business
but um i mean because god almighty
anything can sell a house right now but
the uh but but you know maybe you won't
make 300 but you've got
300 000 of income that many transactions
under your belt
that says you know how to look at people
and get them to the closing table
yeah on the par on the purchase of their
next home their dream yeah you know i
participate with them in that
in a way that causes them to do the
transaction yeah
and and so that is stable yeah and
to your point where your paid or who's
paying you doesn't make it stable right
and to your point your second year if
the market cools off and you take a
small dip
your dip is still way ahead of where you
were in the firemen job so you have to
look at it in relation to what you're
comparing it to as if somehow 70 000 is
stable
when you're talking about even a dip
would still be way above that
which makes his call
for most people listening a no-brainer
yeah
but for something inside of him that was
holding on to this false notion of where
stability comes from
stability comes from your ability
say it again stability comes from
your ability it doesn't come from
anywhere else
and god's blessings but it doesn't come
from anywhere else but those two things
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five
on the la on the debt free stage in the
lobby of ramsey solutions chris
and amanda are with us hey guys how are
you doing very well thank you
welcome welcome good to have you where
do you guys live
ozarks awesome beautiful area huh yeah
it is
cool and all the way down here to do a
debt-free scream how much did you pay
off
278 767
wow how long did this take four years
one month and 19 days i love it and your
range of income during that time
about 130 135 140 somewhere in there
what do you guys do for a living
um we're in higher education both of us
what are your professors uh-huh yeah
cool
good for you yeah thank you i teach
chemistry for a junior college
um i'm a chair over a masters of science
and nursing program and i teach in that
program as well
wonderful awesome very cool so uh
i was gonna say four years and 279 000
might be
a mortgage but that might be student
loans yeah a lot of it we had to pay for
a lot of brains
between the two of us we have been
purchasing brains
yes we have five degrees between the two
of us it's wow
too much we over degreed ourselves
it was wow bad decisions all around
that's okay
i mean your professors
you're using it yeah and you know what
honestly we're lifelong learners
we love to learn you know so it was
really good
we love to teach we love our students
both of us so we're really passionate
about it we just
um you know regrets about getting there
the way that we got there but
um that's okay because we were able to
get out of it and now we're kind of on
the other side of your mirror
it definitely is so how four years ago
the time that you finished the last
degree then
uh yes
yeah we started the program about um a
half a year before i completely finished
my phd
okay okay so you're doing dissertation
and stuff as you're doing it
i was yeah wow what's your phd in uh
educational technology
online teaching is sort of my specialty
so wow
you got a little bit of a future wow you
talk about
stepping into them yeah and a
dissertation a dissertation in the
middle of a pandemic
just leading up to it no no no no you
started four years ago i'm sorry
i'm sorry i am in healthcare so you know
wow
yeah amazing yeah very cool
very cool good for you guys so uh how
long have
so you were you were working on your phd
how long y'all been married
almost 22 years now oh okay yeah so
somewhere along the line of this journey
of gathering degrees and
education and lifelong learning and all
of this
uh five years ago or so something
happened into the 22 marriage
what happened so 2017 uh
well late 2016 we just got to the point
or at least i felt like
you know all the money that was going
out you know versus all what's coming in
it just ended up being
nothing left over it just felt like a
financial abyss at the end of it
so that's how i felt but what about you
yeah i think that
um we are both people of integrity and
we knew
that we were signing for something that
we were eventually going to have to pay
and i think as i got closer and closer
to the end of my
educational journey i was
watching it come my friends some of them
were going bankrupt some of them were
starting to get their bills in the mail
because you know they don't start
billing you for the student loans until
you're out
and so i was seeing the size of their
bills and their bills were like
mortgage payments or more and i mean it
was giving me a visceral reaction
and i think we just both of us just went
oh you know the
the piper's coming like we're going to
have to figure out a plan
to get this taken care of and we're both
people of logic
and it was so nice to have um this to
sort of
latch onto to say okay here's a plan
here's a
proven method that we can use to to sort
of work our way through
step by step yeah connected to us
um you know i watch a lot of youtube
videos and i just was following somebody
who
used the ramsay plan cool and um we got
the book and we both read it and we
decided we were going to get on board
and it was very
let's say i think it was intimidating to
go up against that large number after we
actually
let the monster out of the closet
because it really felt that way but
and i think um you know after we started
budgeting and actually doing it and
following it then we started gaining
confidence
and you know it says it was such a
four-year long journey you know probably
in the middle of it felt you know felt
stagnant but we were making progress so
we kept going
you know but the last year went a lot
faster of course with covet everybody
was at home
so there was no way you're going to
spend money anyway so you know it was
we leveraged the advantage of you know
we were paying off
all the student loans at the end because
they were the big biggest part
yeah and so you know we just kept going
it's gone so we don't have to worry
about it
so i'm i'm interested with um
the amount of education and you said
we're people of logic
um when you uh because so much of what
we
do we approach this through almost
emotion yeah or behavior modification
anyway but when you when you laid down
like the baby steps in front of you or
the death snowball in front of you
it was just instantaneous you just saw
it said okay let's do it
i mean i i think that i watched other
people
sort of on youtube who had done it and
and were successful and i said well it
worked for them
we can make this work for us too but
we've always sort of plowed
face-first into life and just done
things
with a lot of confidence that we we are
a team and we're going to be able to
conquer this thing so i think
this was no different i think i think we
just sort of came into it very
confidently like
it may take us and my first calculation
we did the excel spreadsheet at the very
beginning
was that it was going to be seven years
and you know we got it done in
four a little a little over four um we
just picked up all the overtime and
overload that we could pick up but
what do you attribute the difference the
difference between four and seven
wow i think it just working together at
the same goal versus just kind of doing
whatever
the individual wanted to yeah you were
able to sacrifice deeper than you
thought when you did this
yeah we did we definitely did it's on
the shirt i mean we're a team
and it's so different working together
it's one of those things like my
students there's nothing a student hates
worse than a group
project um really but it's such a
valuable skill
to be able to work with another person
and
to enhance each other's strengths and
also work against each other's
weaknesses
but also to work towards a common goal
you almost
it's it's more than one plus one is two
it's you one plus one is
three you know it's more than that so
team call does have their own little
university emblem there
i love it it's it's pretty cool they
have uniforms
they probably have a soccer team yeah
we're not sports
[Laughter]
well done you guys i'm so proud of you
so okay when people ask now you paid off
279 000 in four years in one month
how did you do that what's the secret to
getting out of debt i think being a team
and sticking to the budget even if you
don't
have the confidence yet i think you gain
that over time and you gotta both show
up to the meeting
you can't get to scape out on it you
can't get to skip a month
yeah and i think working the plan um you
know you find that plan that works
and then you commit yourself to it
you've i mean a million people have said
this on the show but you have to submit
yourself to the actual plan
and not try to do ish um nobody is the
exception nobody's the exception to the
role everybody thinks they're the
exception but
you know the rules are there for a
reason and it works
so yeah they're they're there because
they work with a reason there's nothing
here to punish you it's still
it's to bless you yeah so proud of y'all
thank you very
very well thank you very much who were
your biggest cheerleaders outside the
two of you
uh well obviously the two of us but we
had some family and then i think
and my daughter was amazing yeah hi
ali um and we got a uh smart fester who
has followed us through this whole thing
so now we're actually using him
yeah so he helped us out thank you rick
and then we
um also have an elp with a realtor so
we're oh my god
yeah it was one of the coolest things it
was at the end of all of this we were
able to
um move into our dream home yeah
we got a copy of the legacy journey for
you that's the next chapter in your
story
legacy is all about the what this is all
about and a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away and pay it
forward to somebody
you guys are impressive very well done
stars heroes well done
chris and amanda from ozark missouri's
279
000 paid off at four years in a month
making 135 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
three two one
[Applause]
wow that is so awesome what a great
story
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day lamentations 3
22 23 because of the lord's great love
we are not consumed for his compassions
never fail
they are new every morning great
is your faithfulness
henry ford said the only real mistake is
the one from which
we learn nothing chrissy wright ramsey
personality
is my co-host today here on the air
nathan is with us in
minnesota hi nathan welcome to the
ramsey show
hello thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
so i'm i'm currently an accountant for a
large company
i've been there about 14 years
my gross income is about 180 000 per
year
i'm married i have three small children
my wife and i don't have any debt uh we
have about three hundred thousand
dollars in
iras and and um 401ks through my
employer
to my wife's employer i have about forty
five thousand dollars in
savings uh and right now i
have the opportunity to buy into a
well-established
tax practice with one other person i
currently i have a cpa
my my half investment into the business
would be about a
90 000 uh share
and the gross proceeds of the of the tax
practice is about 200 000
annually so my my cut of that my half
would be about 100 000
and we would operate it as you know s
corpse each
myself and the other individual and so
i'm just
trying to assess you know what that kind
of pay cut would
would mean to my current life situation
where you have 45 000 where are you
getting the other 45 to put
the 90 into it um
actually so i've i've met with the
current tax practice owner and the other
person who
who's looking at buying it and it would
be over uh basically over a two year
time frame so not not next tax season
but the following
so by the time i would be
transitioning into this tax practice i
would have
the 90 000 saved up in cash to just pay
good pay for the half of the business
okay and
uh i assume you project that you can
grow the business then
correct okay and um
the there's going to be one sub s corp
and each of you are going to own 50
that's correct okay all right well i'm
sorry no each of us would
would have an s corp on our on our own
and basically the
so whatever tax returns we or whichever
clients and tax
returns we fill or we fill out we would
uh take those proceeds oh actually okay
so you would have to settle
you would have a book of business and he
would have a book of business but you're
basically sharing office space
under the umbrella of the larger okay
okay all right that works
and that makes it easy to manage and um
you know we know who owns what then that
you actually own
those clients that's correct okay
that's good that's a clean way to do it
i i would suggest you get uh just as a
sidebar
uh some legal advice on putting together
it's not really partnership agreement
but it might actually be
how these two sub-s's are going to
interact share expenses
and you always cover all the negative
things we call them the ds
divorce drug use default disability
death
what happens in the event of these
things and so you address those things
up front but that's a fairly normal
process in the type of business that
you're going into
normally i steer away from partnerships
but this is a unique
this is like a medical practice in a
sense they're a law practice in a sense
that it's done differently so
i'm fine with it right so you make 180
your wife makes what
uh right now she's at about 35
but she she'll be starting a new job
in the fall where she'll be around 60 60
to 65.
okay so you would take an 80 000 pay cut
year one but she would have picked up 35
000 of that
that's correct okay and and her concern
is around
you know right now we have very cheap
health care through my employer that
covers our whole family
and she she would work for a school
and her her health care package to
through her employer is is not nearly as
good as mine so it's really just the
the uncertainty around yeah it's not
that's not that's
whoopty-doopty that's not a big deal
okay yeah you just need to run your
numbers and create a budget based on
this new income
i think when you can see it on paper and
see how you can live on this new income
including whatever healthcare
increase in healthcare costs then you're
going oh yeah we can do it it just feels
scary because you can't see it you
haven't put it on paper yet
but you may have 220 now you'll be at
160
then or 165 then
and uh on your way back to 220 surely to
god you can make it on 160 you don't
have any debt
right it's that perceived fear we were
just talking about yeah
so you chrissy's right you need to the
two of you need to write it down and
actually look at it
when you look at actually what the
health care difference is it's a penance
compared to your income yeah it's not
going to be 10
of your income it's not going to be 5 of
your income
it's going to be 2 of your income that's
affected by this
it's that perceived security because
it's coming from somewhere else and now
you're going to be doing it on your own
and you just need to see how you can do
it and that will help relief from some
of that yeah
your big hit is going from 180 to 100
that's the big hit it's not the health
care
right that is and i calculated i
calculated the hours out and it's only
about
six months of equivalent work uh versus
what i do today in 12 months
you know a little bit of of higher
volume obviously in the tax season which
we'd have to manage through with our
little kids and their schedules and
things but but then i'd have you know
late april through december of of lowell
now i haven't worked so i've been
responsible in your current situation
for
building the book of business where you
are or were you just executing widgets
yeah i i manage um a large portion of
the
of one side of the business so all the
the budgeting and the financial
oversight of it so
well the acquisition of new clients
um no we're we're a large uh yeah that's
what
that's what i'm talking about i thought
so okay so that's a skill you don't have
proven that you'll need to get in order
to raise your one hundred thousand
dollar income to two hundred thousand
dollars
that's a true point yes yeah so we some
you know you're gonna learn about
practice management marketing
client acquisition development of new
new books of business
all of those kinds of things to grow
grow grow grow grow
rather than just simply churning out tax
returns
uh and so that that can be that could be
the challenge of this situation but
there's tremendous upside
and i love the idea of what you're doing
yeah yeah and you could use those slower
seasons to work on those the skills
and clinic client acquisition yeah it's
uh but this is a really good move i
definitely would do this
hayley is with us in dallas haley i'm
short on time go straight to your
question
yes uh hi i'm i lost my job in september
as a director uh making 130 000
uh i'm talking to a recruiter today
for a senior director position fortune
100 company
i'm trying to negotiate a higher salary
but i'm not sure how much i should
negotiate for
have you done your research on what the
company pays what the position pays any
of that kind of digging
yeah i've looked online and i'm not
really sure what to trust as far as the
numbers go
but i i indicated i wanted a 148 000.
okay so you've already put a number out
there
i did she gave me an offer today
for 125 000 which
was really low and i told her it was
that i really wasn't
uh but i was interested in a higher
salary than that
i just don't know since i you know lost
my job and i haven't really gotten a lot
of
callbacks i just didn't want to settle
for something low but i don't know
what's
the right salary well if you're worth
150 in the market i would wait
unless you're unless you're having
trouble paying the bills have you got
some backlog have you got some money
um yeah i'm doing good okay yeah then
you know don't take it lower job just
out of lack of confidence then
but the question is you need to do a
detailed comp study
and uh you know more than one site on
the internet can help you do that
there's plenty of places we do comp
studies around here all the time
on what a senior director in that region
where that company is is being paid
and present that back to the headhunter
and say look this is what the comp study
says
it says they're 25 000 low that puts us
out of the dave ramsey showing the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
hey
it's kelly associate producer for the
ramsay show this episode is over but if
you heard about an event
product or service and didn't have a
chance to write it down don't worry
we list everything you've heard about
during this episode in the podcast show
notes section or head to thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
you